hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga where we left it off
uh in the second game of the 1858 match
between daniel harvest and paul charles
morphy
now uh we uh mixed up the the game order
because the first i showed you the first
game of the match
and then only then i showed you the
king's gambit game that led to the match
but i also made another blender because
the first game of the match that i've
shown
is actually the second game of the match
and only this now that i'm showing you
is actually the first game of the match
it's uh
uh i i i took the uh the uh order of the
games from chessgames.com and
they're the number one number two are
switched so it i mean it's not a
terrible thing that happened but
it would be better if i've shown you the
the first game they played first
but now that you do know this this is
actually the first game of the match and
you've already seen the second game in
the previous video
so without further ado let's check it
out as here uh you've seen the the
the previous game was of a of an insane
quality
and this one is uh well very similar
because here
harvest opens with d4 and this is uh
already showing that he
is uh uh well well ahead well ahead of
his time
regarding opening theory and i don't
know if i mentioned this
harvest is 36 years old at the time this
game was played and morphe is
still of course 21. so d4 and morphe
replies to the queen's pawn opening with
e6 uh also known as the horowitz defense
we have c4 and now d5 we have knight to
c3 and now knight to f6 and we have
transposed into the queen's gambit
declined
and now bishop to f4 you've seen this
move many times in modern games but
uh maybe not all of you know that this
is actually the start of the harvest
attack uh
as this move was first played by by
daniel harvest here not not maybe
the the first time that this move was
played but from notable players
so bishop to f4 and now morphy plays a6
a very a very safe move taking away the
b5 square from white's pieces and later
on he's going to strike in the center
with c5
with e3 preparing to develop the light
square bishop and morphe immediately
strikes with c5 we have knight to f3
and now knight to c6 by morphe we have
a3
and c captures on d4 we have e captures
on d4 and now
d captures in c4 so morphe just trades
everything
uh bishop captures on c4 and now b5
a6 move allows this move to be played
and now you also free up the b7 square
for the bishop
to grab hold of this very long diagonal
and now there is one game i think from
2004 where bishop to a2 was played
but after bishop to d3 it is as of move
10 the disposition has never been
reached again
so morphe continues development we have
bishop to b7
and now harvest castles uh we have
bishop to e7 morphy also prepares the
castle
and now bishop to e5 it's um
it's a very interesting idea because uh
you hear morphe has the opportunity to
grab
one of one of his opponent's bishops but
after this is
played for example captures and captures
uh then this pawn
is is a pretty great piece and whatever
morphe plays knight d7 id5
uh you will constantly have to worry
about this diagonal
and if the queen can join the attack
because now these squares are
not available for for the knight anymore
so it kind of weakens black structure
uh but it is playable uh morphe instead
goes for castles
uh in the now queen to e2 continuing
development
and um connecting rooks the rooks can
now be developed c1 d1 e1 and so on
and moves like knights to e4 can be
played because then if captures and
captures then the queen
assumes this very nice diagonal as well
so here
morphe could continue just developing
queen to b6 is always an option he could
still trade on e5 connect the rooks
but morphe goes knight to d5 and it's a
kind of a counter-intuitive move because
you uh move pieces away from the defense
and you have to respect the bishop pair
you know if you don't respect the bishop
pair bad things will happen
so here bishop back to g3 and now morphy
plays king to h8
it's um hard to say why king to h8 uh
because there there currently aren't any
threats you don't have to worry about
any bishop captures an h7 with
check as the g5 square is covered many
times uh but i think morphy was just uh
preparing to open up the g file for
for his rook so here rook after e1 and
bishop to f6 now
we have queen to e4 taking advantage of
the knight no longer occupying the f6
square and now morphy has only one move
that doesn't
result in checkmate and that is g6 so
the mate
has been prevented and here harvest goes
for a trade knight captures on d5
and now morphe has to has the trade uh
capturing with
this pawn uh is possible but then yeah
queen to f4 will put a lot of pressure
on black's position and while it is
playable morphe prefers queen captures
on d5 here
he offers a queen trait and probably
wanted to test out uh
harvest's uh uh endgame skills and like
i said this is actually game one of
their match
so here harvest accepts queen captures
on d5 e captures on the e5
and now the immediate knight to e5
taking advantage
of the pawn uh being uncapturable
because if you capture it then just
knight here and you lose the rook
well the exchange the bishop has to move
otherwise you're going to lose a piece
and if you don't then it's uh just bad
uh
you have to play something like bishop
g7 captures captures and then white will
be up the exchange
so here instead after knight to e5
morphe played rook 8 to d8 now taking
away the d7 square from the white's
knight
and now knight captures on c6 we have
bishop captures and here if you look at
this position both players have
six spawns both players have the bishop
player what players have the rook pair
uh but uh morphy's uh pawns here on the
queen side are all on light squares he
has a light square bishop
which makes uh harvard's plan all that
more uh
uh well natural rook the c1 puts
pressure on the bishop murphy defends it
with rook to c8
and now a bishop to e5 right away can be
played but harvest goes for the even
better bishop to d6 he first puts
pressure on the rook
uh you can't really play rook to e8
because then just rook captures and you
have to
uh well remove one of the one of these
guys and then
uh you just grab one of the other pieces
we can even show it if you play
something like
rook here that just rook captures any
eight with check and it doesn't matter
what uh
you recapture with if you recapture with
the bishop then the rook falls if you
recapture with the rook
then the bishop falls and you don't have
to worry about any checkmates because
you always have bishop to f1
after this check it's not a problem so
instead after bishop to d6 morphy has to
move the rook he decides to go for rook
to g8
uh rook to d8 is also possible then
bishop to e7 of course comes and the
white will be able to
get the rook all the way to the seventh
rank so instead
rook to g8 and now bishop to e5 this is
the app
this is absolutely the correct plan you
have to trade off the dark square
bishops
because then morphy will only be left
with a light square bishop and all of
his pawns are on light square so
that's the definition of a bad bishop so
here uh
morphy uh decides to go for king to g7
and here
again loventhal takes an opportunity to
scold morphe for his decision
so logantos says that uh capturing the
bishop is the way to go in this position
and then
harvest couldn't really push for any
advantage and it's a very
interesting and bold claim because uh if
you allow the engine to crunch the
numbers the the engine says both moves
are
maybe of equal worth and if the engine
has to pick a favorite
then uh capturing the bishop is the
engine's favorite so love on top
definitely on to something but
in some normal terms for humans uh came
to g7 also very playable
uh but okay uh king to g7 by morphe and
now
f4 cementing that bishop on e5 uh with
bishop to d7 morphe now offers a trade
of rooks and now
king to f2 uh harvard starts bringing
the king into the game as this is what
you should always do in an end game
uh we have h6 by morphe and now king to
e3
activating the king even further morphy
trades a pair of rooks we have captures
and captures and now
bishop to c8 uh sorry not nazi rook the
c8
just offering yet another trade uh and
here rook to c5 of course you don't want
to trade because that makes uh
uh black's life uh a lot easier so here
rook to c5
saying to morphy if you want to capture
i'm gonna get a very nice pass pawn here
so morphe first grabs the bishop on e5
with
f captures on e5 and now bishop to e6
and now morphy says
okay this is uh now perfectly fine for
me i don't think you have anything
that you can do but a bad bishop is a
bad bishop and
while the bishop is on e6 it's it's more
of a pawn than a bishop so here
uh harvard starts uh by challenging
murphy's queen side and he plays
a4 and okay morphy captures it with b
captures on a4
bishop captures on a6 and now comes rook
to b8
rook to a8 maybe maybe is a safer move
attacking the bishop and immediately
defending the spawn
but okay morphe decides to go for rook
to b8 and now rook to b5
not allowing morphe to capture the spawn
we have rook to d8 now
if we now go here then bishop b7 is also
very strong with a double attack on this
pawn
so rook to d8 defending the spawn and
now rook to b6
making room for the bishop to leave the
a6 square
rook the a8 now by morphy and only now
king to d2
uh so the king will now help out with
the defense of the of the queenside
pawns with bishop the c8
offering a trade but it also means that
morphe will be
down a pawn so here bishop captures uh
with rook captures on c8 and
now rook to b5 going after the pawn here
rook to a8 and now uh harvest just grabs
the d5 pawn brook captures and now
morphy plays a3 and he will either get a
beautiful pass spawn here
or harvest will have to capture
capturing is of course best we have
captures captors
and now rook to c5 making room for the
past pawn to be pushed forward
and it's a very safe position for
harvest uh morphy can't reach the king
side pawns because if you check harvest
just defend uh defends and you cannot
trade rooks because upon up here is uh
just
just winning for harvest so uh morphe
instead
goes king to fate starts bringing his
king into the game king to e2 now
now any checks can be met with king of
three and the pawns get defended
king is seven we have d5 now and look at
these
beautiful pawns controlling all of these
squares this is not
not a pleasant position for morphy to be
in we have kinked a d7
and now rook to c6 preparing rook to f6
to go after the f7 pawn
uh and here was probably the last good
moment for morphe to go for some sort of
a perpetual here with
check king f3 check king f4 if king a4
then rook back to a2 you go after these
pawns
and it's maybe possible to play this but
morphy started with h5 instead
uh just going for an improved pawn
structure i i guess
and now comes rook to f6 going after the
pawn here
morphy says no problem king the e7 again
king that e8 is better here
but it's uh it's um only as means of
guarding the spawn and you prevent the
d6 because d6 now
is met with the very unpleasant rook to
a5 threatening to capture with
check and after e6 you still get f
captures
rook captures with check and king to f7
and now
uh now it's it's perfectly fine
uh because this move now which is
incredibly dangerous is met with rook to
d5 so you don't have to worry about
anything and this is now this is not
just a draw
uh but morphe went kink the e7 and this
allows harvest to
execute the pawn push with check so here
we have d6 with
check king the e8 and now uh you're
playing the white pieces uh you are
harvest uh feel free to pause the video
and
win the game uh uh against morphy well i
give you a couple of seconds i know you
like morphe but you still have to find
the best move
i'm sorry
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
master of the end game
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's of course
e6 this just crushes through the
position
and now you see why that rook to a5
maneuver was so important because here
uh you don't really gain anything if you
start checking rookie to check
king e3 uh you simply allow the white
king to go up the board because any
captures here are just made with d7
check king is seven and now even this
and now who who can stop all of these
queens it's just game over
so instead after e6 uh morphe played f
captures on e6 now come to rook captures
on e6 with check
king f7 but now the move that we
mentioned uh
actually works d7 this is what harvest
plays and now there is no rook to d3 to
defend against the queening
and of course capturing the rook uh just
uh why it brings the queen into the game
so after d7 morphy's next movie is
forced we have rook to a8
guarding the queening square we have
rooked the d6 preparing the queen and
now
aking to d7 attacking the rook and
guarding the queening square twice
so now harvest is uh free to gobble up
the king side pawns
rook captures on g6 is played king
captures on d7 and now rogue g5 going
after the last remaining pawn
we have rooked the h8 and now comes king
to f3
we have king to e6 morphe starts
bringing the king closer but now
king to g3 we have h4 with check
and now king to g4 and now morphy's last
attempt at a trick h3
uh of course if uh harvest captures it
then this is a well-known draw there's
no way to
uh to win this with with the uh uh
the the h pawn doubled up uh but here of
course after h3 harvest has just played
the g3
and now there's nothing really for
morphe to do he played king f6 but now
rook h5
and he was in this position that paul
morphy resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
if you trade rooks of course uh the pawn
will be easily won
and that's just game and if you don't if
you play something like
check then the king wins the pawn and of
course you're up two points this is a
completely winning end game
so yeah this is basically the first game
of their match and then comes the second
game
of the match that you've seen where
harvest played a really really
impressive game
with the black pieces uh i mean it was a
really
a game of high quality and you as you
can see here morphe didn't really play
uh all that ambitious uh but it's
something that um
uh that edge morphy's companion on the
trip often said that morphe didn't
really
do all that much in the first games of
the match uh and the morphe didn't
really
uh seem like he was bothered by losing
this even though harvest was the most
unpleasant uh there is a
uh there is uh saying that uh uh harvest
uh
after defeating morphe he even uh
grabbed his hand
and uh he he kind of pull felt his pulse
and he said uh you know in front of
everyone that uh morphy's pulse
remains the same it doesn't matter if
he's winning or losing or
uh basically that uh
i don't know what he even wanted to say
by this but he was most unpleasant
and he made a remark that it takes very
little trouble to beat
this fellow and uh edge was very very
nervous about this morphe was losing
by two points in a match and he said
that he would uh you know
uh offer any stakes that that harvest
chooses so like i said uh
if harvest chose like a million dollars
morphy morphy would
also stake that and uh no one was uh
you know everyone was angry because
other people placed bets as well and
they thought of course everyone heard of
morphe they thought morphy would just uh
crush him
uh but uh morphy set the f at edge
when they were you know strolling the
town enjoying uh paris that
there was nothing to worry about and
these were his words he said uh how
astonished all these men are going to be
uh horowitz will not win another game so
that's a that's a pretty bold claim
morphe lost
the the first game but okay he kind of
threw that one to to even get a match
against harvest but now he's already
down by two points in the match
so will morphy be able to uh to support
uh his claim that harvest will not
win a single game anymore we'll see
because as you've seen harvest is quite
a fighter we already mentioned how he
was losing to levantal
uh nine to one and then he won the match
11-10
so he is definitely a fighter we'll see
if morphe can turn this
around so that's the second game of the
match hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank uh
patrick sivitz uh joseph paloca uh
ronald neath uh
robert arthur and john wamsley for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday